hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I want to run the
marathon no I want to run the marathon
is a version of I want to be the guy and
I want to be the guy who's a game that's
gonna make you rage your intestines not
really if you know what you're doing and
you have some patience but when have you
ever known me to have that sort of stuff
but some say this one's even better than
the original in fact it was a game that
was played during games done quick I
don't know if it was this year or if it
was recently but there have been others
that have been made and this is one of
them this game is really simple right
I want to be the guys game where you're
a little kid and you've got a gun and
the means with which to jump and shoot
you've got a double jump and that's all
there is to it so once we get going with
everything you'll see what it's alright
ah that's okay I should have known
something like that was gonna happen I
should've known the tree was gonna
descend on me this is actually the first
screen of I want to be the guy I always
start over wait hang on wait what no
wait a minute wait a minute I just
closed the game oh come on now okay I
know there's got to be a there is a way
to not have to exit the game I know that
so it's got to be true
please tell me that's a true all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay that's that's pretty [ __ ] oh how do
I go again oh there we go
wait no what I did now this isn't I want
to be the guy this is I want to run raw
because I want to run the
marathon which this means that I need to
be a bit more intelligent about this
okay ha ha ha ha ha bond we eat oh okay
[Laughter]
that's not what I wanted at all oh no oh
no oh come on
I'm really trying
yeah you all clenched out there because
I'm gonna need it a lot this ooh baby oh
[Music]
no no okay it's like the ghosts from
Mario Brothers on like that oh come on
okay we're just gonna go for it we're
gonna go for it we're gonna go for it oh
no no no come and shoot nope
it's surprisingly it don't work hope
[Music]
okay doing it oh no come on
that's gotta be that's gotta be the one
and so I just gotta trick this one thing
ha ha ha okay now I got it
okay this last one will in the back all
right we're getting through this how am
I gonna get through this Oh No
but that's how you do it that's how you
do it okay pop easy peasy
oh you turd sandwich you oh you turd
sandwich you oh no yoo-hoo
- you how oh boy oh boy
ah you just need to go all the way over
okay I got this okay I got this I got
this ha ha ha oh no oh no oh no my brain
can't handle this timing all the neurons
are firing in my brain telling me to run
run markiplier run run away from this
never return and yet here I stand okay
oh I didn't even make it all the way Oh
tip my sprinkles oh god alright
run run markiplier run there's a
terrible place to be ah sorry just need
to get my vocal lessons out of the way
man you ever just remember how much you
suck every day day in and day out you
just constantly reminded that you're
just a garbage human being and that
everything you do is always gonna be
trash so why even bother in life do you
remember that do you ever think that
guys you ever look in the mirror and
just a recognized by nothing except your
own failures as you as you go through
life day by day being reminded of all
the things that you didn't do right in
your life you ever there's gonna be a
long night by the way so everybody
better buckle up you better get some
goddamn snacks because it's gonna be oh
it's gonna be a major overhaul before I
get out of here yeah like a gentle
butterfly woof I slam my fell faith
faith faith in today of oh boy how many
times I'm gonna land on the spike
directly on my butthole oh man I mean
it's no other I explode into a spear of
blood it's like straight sparing man
no this is wrong oh no that was right
okay
no I hesitated that was fine why did I
think I was saved therefore even but a
moment why did I think my butt was saved
there even for a butt moment well I'm
never gonna be able to make this how in
the Frick frack and [ __ ] duck how how
would I do this I ask you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh man
my [ __ ] my [ __ ] being speared on
spikes iiiii one of these days off in my
brain for the timing of this nope
not that time you know I said one of
these days that day could be infinity
time from now when I actually learned my
lesson oh if I could just get my brain
to work you know you know some people
say you only use 10% of your brain I'm
operating at a cool 2% it's basically
like the consistency of milk inside my
noggin
and it's just as delicious oh god I
hesitated why did I hesitate I just need
to not hesitate on that one moment
that's all I got to do oh I got a do oh
oh you're Rick your frikar oh yes okay
good
oh ha ha what am I doing here what am I
even doing what how are you gonna mess
with me next is my answer because if I
fall down that hole I am bald
ah all right I got this I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I don't know why I did
that everyone asking why you think I
know why I don't I really don't I don't
know why I did that I panicked I had
opportunity inside McLaws and I just I
did nothing with it oh god right on my
ballsack again again on my balls
Wow no no no no no I'm angry girl look
how why why am i doing that I I'm just
being a big old sack of poopie
oh god I'm doing it again and again
getting better at it though that's a
nice thing now I say as I smash my taint
upon the rocks once more twice more how
about a third time there we go that's
the charm Oh new one huh oh really
okay all right okay all right
Oh what's weird about this game as I
start to become dissociated from the
character like for some reason my Britta
my brain isn't quite like translating
that this guy is what I'm controlling
for some reason every time I responded
like throws me off oh man just give
another excuse to how my brain doesn't
work right now how in the hell does it
expect me to do this okay
ah and slammed baited I didn't even try
I didn't even try I didn't even try oh I
didn't even try oh I'm not even trying
anymore
come on I'm doing it as gently as I
could oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh I'm as gentle as
a butterfly
oh oh oh sorry
another one of my vocal warm-ups said I
just had to get out of my chest okay
that's what do you want huh
[Music]
nope oh okay what trick what trap
there's gonna be a trap huh huh oh yeah
whoo
ha OH
I mean I know it's gonna be hard enough
as it is
boy that looks awful oh you dick hole oh
you dick hole
oh you hole of dick you hold dick oh you
hold dick okay okay
and jump no I didn't trigger it in a hub
kind of faith in my own skills which I
do not have and nobody should have man
if my skills were a stock it would be
tanking right now oh boy I hate why I
hate I hate life hi hey oh I hate life
okay you guys didn't ever think about
life and how much I hate it I thought my
new hit single oh I don't like that it
takes me 10 tries to just get past the
beginning every goddamn time oh I got a
random timer or something is that what
you are is that what you are to me is
that what I am to you why it wasn't time
to go so why did I go I'll never know
look at the snow oh I'll watch me blow
up whoa haha I just wanted to catch that
little point on my vowel right before it
goes in the ground I wanted to make sure
I got a sweet taste of that one oh I
never knew when it was gonna come around
again oh boy and just set the record
straight yes I did enjoy it I did I did
I really did don't oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
alrighty then that's the mating call of
the what the [ __ ] bird I can't get this
to save my life I mean obviously because
I keep dying so much I can't get this
because my life is over
okay there we go that time you were
great okay
[Music]
give me a second you can't tell me that
that left jutting son-of-a-bitch right
over there isn't finicky like what the
hell
what kind of attitude adjustment do you
need okay Oh God yes yes yes yes I'll
get it with these big old bad boys
[Music]
you